from Warner Brothers Studios in
Hollywood it's the konanov E&C Awards
celebrating excellence in the sitting
and looking arts here now is your host
Conan O'Brien
thank you very much you know first of
all for a night this important I think I
should dress the part don't you Bruce
help me out here we go we're all set we
have man has no joy in his work
absolutely non Bruce all right first of
all let's give it up for this audience
see statuette right here isn't this
thing beautiful yeah absolutely gorgeous
was modeled on Vin Diesel sitting on a
toilet and then and no genitalia so
that's the rumor of in any way it's a
real rumor out there that's a real rumor
I'm not trying to spread it I'm just
saying that's your real rumor Vin Diesel
no genitals anyway our first audience
you bored and these are big big Awards
as you can see you get one of these and
you are set for life our first audience
award is for the best impression of a
celebrity and the audience he goes to
the person in seat 5d for their
impression of actor Riz Ahmed
the next high density award is also for
best impression of a celebrity and the
audience he goes to the person in seat
7j for their impression of marcy from
peanuts
[Music]
why that is not a slab Marcy's like the
coolest I'd be happy with that
I'd take that any day alright our next
audience he goes to the person in seat
12 l the award for the audience member
most likely to have a membership at
mar-a-lago he sees the president there
all the time they go off together it's a
good time next audience he goes the
person in seat 11b
it's the award for the audience member
most likely to be more beard than man
say that beard grew him that's
incredible
it's turned as a beard and then slowly
over time a man formed the next audience
he goes the person in seat 21 seeds the
word for the guy who hasn't watched the
news in a couple of years
[Music]
our next audience award because the
person making the most of their downtime
during my show's taping it's the
audience member currently recording
their own podcast today on Alyssa's
universe my comedian buddies stopped by
to share personal finance tips recaps
Sunday's Westworld and closed in on the
trail of a brutal murderer but first a
pledge for blue apron or accurate than
funny all right
we're out here every night at what do
you want Joe's free hey the next award
goes to the person in seat 5b it's the
award for the audience member who came
best prepared for our show
it's not funny
like any awards show we have our own red
carpet correspondent he also happens to
be one of our shows union certified
transportation drivers Lenny Gert yeah
let's let's see some Lenny Gert red
carpet highlights from before tonight's
show
[Music]
the next audience II ghost the person in
seat 8f it's the award for the audience
member who is seeing the show for the
very first time congratulations
it's a healthy new audience member
very realistic and finally the biggest
award of the night the lifetime
achievement for Best Overall audience
and the nominees are tonight's audience
last night's audience and
as your ass'll and of course dr. Phil's
audience
[Applause]
and the winner is dr. Phil's audience
wait I'm being told dr. Phil's audience
couldn't be here tonight we're here to
accept the award on their behalf it's
tonight's audience
here you can have the podium
hereis yeah that podium that's here yeah
it's that's yours for the rest of the
show all right we're gonna uh we're
we're taking that [ __ ] back that's
expensive
you